as we're preparing to uh uh publish this
show we got breaking news FDX founder
Sam bankman Fred has been found guilty
on all charges including multiple counts
of fraud conspiracy and money laundering
it's kind of funny he's a a big Democrat
donor and there's also talk about wasn't
he the guy who was like offering Trump
hypothetically billions of dollars not
to run for president was that him
hypothetically yeah hyp it was that was
that was that was what was going on it
was never confirmed but people were
saying hey he might have offered like
how much would you like if to not run
for president I think there was a bunch
of people that were close to him that
actually said that he who was was
offering that or something okay so this
is breaking news right now uh the other
story we were planning on leading off
with is that a judge in in uh uh I'm
sorry in Connecticut overturned a
Democrat primary after video emerged of
ballot stuffing and the interesting
thing about this is that it's not a
victory the general election is still
happening and it is presumed that the
candidate who should not be the
candidate on the ballot is still going
to win